[Musica]
può un sistema di intelligenza
artificiale capire la complessità di una
partita di calcio meglio di jurgen klopp
pep guardiola e josè mourinho e possono
sofisticati modelli matematici cambiare
le stragi e di gioco di una squadra in
tempo reale
meglio di come potrebbe fare una mente
umana super allenata per fare solo
questo
beh io non so quale sia la vostra idea
ma so che tra qualche minuto potrebbe
essere diversa
siamo infatti iniziando un viaggio oltre
la crosta superficiale della partita di
calcio
un viaggio alla ricerca di quelle
concatenazioni causa effetto che
determinano l'andamento delle partite e
spesso anche il loro esito
un viaggio sorprendente come grande fu
la sorpresa che accolse heisenberg
quando approdato sull'isola di el gola
nel mare del nord nel 1925 scoprì una
strana bellezza quella della fisica
quantistica dello spazio e del tempo
ecco noi entreremo dentro le relazioni
spazio temporali della partita di calcio
e lo facciamo subito attraverso questa
azione della nazionale italiana vista
prima con la ripresa televisiva e poi
andiamo a esplorare questa azione con un
animazione 2d che ci permette di vedere
le zone di campo dinamiche più
strategiche dandogli un significato che
poi noi traduciamo attraverso un nome e
un cognome ad esempio chiamando ampiezza
le zone laterali rifinitura la zona tra
le due linee di centrocampo e difesa e
profondità la zona oltre la linea
difensiva
ecco praticamente stanno facendo un
viaggio dal mondo della realtà fisica il
luogo degli oggetti al mondo della
realtà metafisica il luogo dei concetti
dando un segno un segno distintivo ad
ognuno di questi bene di fatto abbiamo
creato un metalinguaggio
delle forme mutevoli del calcio questa è
la nostra direzione
un intreccio di contaminazione
interdisciplinare dalla fisica alla
metafisica dalla matematica alla
statistica in questo percorso non
potevamo non incontrare l'arte si è
perché qualche anno mi sono imbattuto in
un breve saggio di disegno del pittore
rusco russo kandinsky che utilizzava il
punto la linea e la superficie per
tracciare le dimensioni del disegno e mi
colpì molto sin dal titolo perché io già
da anni utilizzava gli stessi elementi
per analizzare la partita di calcio
andiamoli a vedere il punto lo strato
più superficiale del calcio che possiamo
pensare come una torta a tre strati dove
il punto è esattamente dove il giocatore
incontro al pallone
un momento magico che catalizza
l'attenzione di tutti ecco quel punto
poi si unisce ad altri punti creando
delle linee stava entrando nel secondo
strato della nostra torta quello dei
passaggi che alla fine non è altro che
una forma di linguaggio non verbale che
i giocatori usano in campo per
comunicare tra loro delle intese
istintive che permettono di definire un
tipo di azione che può essere un'azione
verticale un contropiede molto veloce
oppure un'azione manovrata con tanti
passaggi preparatori orizzontali ma
perché le squadre adottano una strategia
o un'altra strategia per capirlo per
andare nelle cause
dobbiamo andare nel terzo strato della
nostra torta quello più profondo che
quello delle contrapposizioni delle
superfici delle due squadre dei poligoni
che si muovono è intrecciandosi tra di
loro
e siccome a noi non ci interessa la
metrica esatta di queste dimensioni ma
ci interessa il significato cognitivo
calcistico ci viene incontro la
topologia e nessuno
meglio di poincaré ce la può spiegare
attraverso la sua congiuntura lui poneva
e si poneva questa domanda
un pallone da calcio e un pallone da
rugby sono uguali e sono diversi
ecco secondo la geometria e forse
secondo anche il nostro percepito
diremmo che è sono diversi perché il
pallone da calcio ha una superficie
circolare il profilo del pallone da
rugby e ovale invece per puntare sono
due figure uguali perché non hanno
discontinuità nelle loro superficie sono
due figure piene
ecco passa poi poi in care a rapportare
un clown con una ciambella sono uguali
sono diverse dal punto di vista
geometrico sono entrambe figure
circolari per cui dovrebbero essere
questa volta uguale invece può in
careggi spiega che sono diverse perché
il club è naturalmente lo conosciamo
tutti una figura piena come due palloni
visti in precedenza mentre la ciambella
c'è un buco
ecco nel calcio si va alla ricerca di
questi buchi e ve lo faccio vedere
maniera semplice attraverso un dialogo
che ho ricostruito con un po di fantasia
tra callejon e il suo compagno di
squadra zielinski dove callejon dice al
compagno guarda io mi allargo porto
fuori il difensore avversario dalla
difesa crafen della squadra avversaria
a quel punto crea un buco la difesa
diventa a ciambella the entra in quella
ciambella e vai a fare gol
benissimo se mi avete seguito fino ad
ora possiamo andare oltre e parlare di
cristiano ronaldo di un gol fatto in
champions league da cristiano ronaldo un
paio di anni fa
vediamo prima la solita ripresa
televisiva che ci fa vedere l'aspetto
visibile superficiale dell'azione
vediamo un'azione veloce concretizzata
poi da cristiano ronaldo con un grande
colpo di testa e poi andiamo a rivedere
questa azione attraverso la sua matrice
spazio temporale e scopriamo che la
difesa della squadra avversaria
l'ajax inizialmente a casa
non ci sono buchi nella profondità di
cui abbiamo parlato precedentemente poi
improvvisamente cristiano ronaldo quando
riceve il pallone fa una scelta diversa
si gira di spalle non punta l'avversario
attirando su di sé il difensore come una
calamita e creando improvvisamente una
voragine alle spalle della difesa
dell'ajax che diventa a ciambella e il
suo compagno di squadra che gli va
passato il pallone bentancur vedo quello
spazio ci si butta dentro lo aggredisce
e poi continua la sua corsa verso il
primo palo portando con sé un altro
difensore creando un altro buco un'altra
ciambella che vedono i compagni di
squadra che vede cancello che farà il
cross in quel basket e che vede più sono
ronaldo che arriva e farà gol in quel
buco bene se questa è la causa di quel
viaggio della palla se queste sono le
cause che noi dobbiamo andare a
ritrovare per capire il calcio
la domanda che faccio e questa possono
sistemi tecnologici oggi trovare queste
cause in automatico e in tempo reale
bene la risposta è affermativa
c'è un modello adottato dalla lega serie
a che permette di vedere le partite di
calcio attraverso delle telecamere
speciali appuntamento missilistico che
riescano a distinguere i pixel delle
maglie dei giocatori dal background del
campo e quindi a darci le xy dei loro
movimenti 20 frame al secondo
questi rodata poi viaggiano velocemente
sul cloud dove incontrano degli
algoritmi molto sofisticati di
intelligenza artificiale che attraverso
l'analisi di questi di queste tre di
queste traiettorie e la mano delle
visualizzazioni e delle degli indicatori
di prestazione che vengono restituiti in
tempo reale con zero tempo di latenza
nelle panchine degli allenatori e gli
allenatori possono guardare queste
informazioni per capire meglio la
partita migliorare i loro processi
decisionali
adesso vi faccio vedere un piccolo video
dove si vede questa app tablet in
funzione
ma fa a san siro milan atalanta e si
vedono sul tablet e le visualizzazioni
di quelle aree di pertinenza dei
giocatori di cui parlavamo prima
e poi si vedono degli indicatori
assolutamente innovativi e rivoluzionari
per capire una partita come l'indicatore
di pericolosità di una squadra oppure
l'indicatore di pressione esercitata o
subita dai giocatori oppure la
disponibilità di un attaccante a
ricevere palla il passe risk
ecco tutto questo arrivo in panchina ma
sono milioni di dati come fa un
allenatore a capire qual è quello che
gli può servire bene tornando alla
quantistica
questi dati vengono pacchettizzati
inviati in panchina solo quelli più
utile all'allenatore e viviamo questa
azione
andiamo a vedere un'azione entriamo in
panchina e vediamo cosa vedrebbe
l'allenatore questa nazione dell'inter
che porterà un gol contro la juventus
inizia col portiere che ha la palla nei
piedi e deve decidere cosa fare ecco
quello è il punto è l'analisi appunti
uno strato superficiale della nostra
torta
tutti vedono quel punto nessuno vede che
lontano dall'altra parte del campo
sta nascendo la causa di come si
svilupperà il gioco il terzino opposto
della juventus decide di andare alto
lasciando un buco dietro di sé e la
mezzala dell'inter già vede quel buco
bastoni riceve la palla dal portiere e
lo vede anche lui barella parte in
quello spazio bar
il difensore parte con il suo lancio in
quello spazio che il virtual coach così
si chiama questo strumento aveva già
predetto e quindi si crea un viaggio
della palla che è la conseguenza di
questa matrice spazio temporale questo è
quello che oggi un sistema di
intelligenza artificiale può fare e
allora attorno alla domanda iniziale
questo è una minaccia è un'opportunità
per un allenatore è la risposta la
faccio dare da mauro berruto ex
commissario tecnico della nazionale di
volley che ha detto ogni informazione
che mi arriva da un sistema tecnologico
che può vedere oltre
e quello che vedono i miei occhi può
aumentare la mia conoscenza e quindi può
aumentare la mia capacità di allenare
grazie